I'm and my
partner my
ising is
hyal farming it is a practice of growing
FR which tack like in the indust it is
introduced it is developed by the Dix
and in the year of 1999 he was the
environmental health scientist in
Columbia University as you can see it is
a water tank which Supply water to the
every portion of the without missing you
can it down how the water is transported
to the so we are using here dripping
system dripping system will help the
plants for suppl of water the dripping
system means we are inserting holes to
the plants and with along with the water
we are adding man mix to so water it
will give nutrients to the
plants hydroponic form Hydro water plant
the plant which grows in the water that
is called hydroponic form
demonstrated by John socks in the year
of
1960 what I want to explain how the
plant will grows here we have set
one will the water to theer can and will
flow to
the so we are using man Mi it is
prepared by the cang and it is purify in
this tank and will get the liquid that
we are spray to the
plants it will help the plant away from
the Ines and next is p p p is natural
fertilizer and it will the booster of
the plant growth and it helps to the
control of the pest and it helps to the
uh good fruits good production and um
away from the Beats for the products of
the pun
andk
and and first we have to mix the and G
for 4 days and we have to decompos for 4
days after deos decompos days we have to
add add all the products and we have to
decompose it for 10 or two weeks 10 or
days and decompos and have to St that
for one day two days
is for
theity so next watering system imagine
if you are going to a trip for one or
two weeks they had
a the plants will the doubt is
clearly are taking a box and inserting H
in that H the water plant should be
correctly inserted and we have to add
water in the and in the water plant on
the Bas we have to put holes and we have
to get put the good water absor such as
cotton and wood we are promoting cotton
for absortion of water the the cotton
will absorb water and it helps the soil
to moisture when the soil is moist will
be moisture The Roots will observe the
moist of the soil if you want to add any
organic soltion solution
we can
directly if it is in the we can directly
in the water and it is absor with and it
is Lally absorbed by the roots
and benefits of partical farming
nowadays we can see the soil fertility
is decreasing day by day so we have to
promote these types of farming for
goodal for farmers who are the small and
marginalized Farmer they have to promote
this types of farming who are putting
the high income in the chemical inputs
they have to promote this type of F and
it is only it is only is natural it will
not damage our environment it is
eco-friendly in the nature so that
finally we want to conclude that we have
to promote these types of system in our
country for the for the protection of
our
environment thank you